Today for our experts in emotion interview.
We have the honor of speaking with Dr. Kent Berridge on pleasure and reward in
the brain.
Kent Berridge is the James Old collegiate professor of psychology and
neuroscience and the Department of Psychology at the University of Michigan.
Bear just current research focuses on answering questions such as how is
pleasure generated in the brain,
is happiness on the brain and how do wanting and liking interact?
He also answers questions such as what causes addiction.
Does fear share anything with desire and can an emotion ever be unconscious?
Um,
Doctor Berridge serves on editorial boards for several scientific journals and
he's Co edited the book pleasures of the brain and among many honors,
um,
beverage has been a Guggenheim fellow and a Fulbright senior scholar.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion interview with Dr. Kent Berridge on
pleasure and reward in the human brain.
Welcome,
Ken.
Thanks for speaking with us.
Well,
thank you Jen,
for including me in your series.
Oh,
it's a pleasure.
I know that one of the things that many people out there would want to know
about you is what first got you started or interested in the study of emotion
and pleasure in the first place?
Well,
I've always thought that emotion,
pleasure an asset.
I sort of essential qualities of psychological experience,
you know,
something that we'd love to be able to launch a steam and there were
opportunities to appropriate a bit and it's been fun.
Excellent.
And so I want to move now just to a few questions about your research,
which is very,
very exciting and I,
I feel honored to be able to speak with you about it today.
So the first question I wanted to ask you is just a bit about your work that's
really,
you know,
paved the way for understanding distinctions between anticipation or wanting of
rewards on the one hand from the conservatory experience or liking of rewards.
On the other hand,
and I wondered if you could elaborate on this really interesting distinction
between wanting versus liking.
Well,
it's a distinction that we sort of stumbled upon.
We weren't ever expecting it,
but it turns out that the brain seems to make a big distinction between its
mechanisms of liking something and its mechanisms of wanting that same thing.
We actually started many years ago looking at dopamine thinking it was going to
be a mechanism of liking.
There is so much reason to think that don't mean wasn't pleasure mechanism in
the brain that was causing her liking and in our hands it seemed not to do that.
And that led us to puzzle.
How could dopamine look like wanting and look sorry,
I look like liking but yet not be liking.
And that led us to the possibility that wanting with something don't mean could
do that would sort of go along with like unusual.
So in what way have the tools of neuroscience that you've used heavily in your
work supported this distinction between liking versus wanting?
Well,
they've helped us these tools to tease apart the brain mechanisms of like
conversion,
loyalty.
But you know what?
We really want to stress that the tools are really sort of a,
they give you an opportunity for an open ended question.
The answer could have been that there was no difference.
You know,
that dopamine was liking or that the mechanisms of liking and wants to do
whatever they are are always bound in separately together.
The answer was not that the answer was that they came apart and that was a
product of the tools.
But the tools of course,
they just need you to wherever the truth is and the truth is out there
somewhere.
That's a lovely way to think about it.
As you know,
being a scientist,
you're really trying to discover the truth that's already there and you just
sort of stumble upon whatever it's going to tell you.
Well I think it helps to have an open mind.
Yes,
we do these things,
you know,
I mean we all get attached to our theories and our hypotheses and we all get a
little bit disappointed when the results turn out not to be [inaudible].
I was disappointed actually at first when don't put wasn't pleasure like you
really thought that we were going to help confirm that.
Um,
but often what turns out to be actually true is more interesting in the end.
Then what we saw was true in the beginning.
So I think if we start with an open mind,
we end up in a good place.
Excellent.
I mean in your work,
you know,
on trying to understand pleasure and reward and teasing apart wanting and liking
has not only had these kind of basic science implications but it's really
generated important sites into disorders that involve dysregulated reward
functioning,
you know,
such as addiction for example in some of the work you're doing.
And I wonder if you could share what you see as some of the most exciting
discoveries in this sort of clinical or translational realm of your work.
Well,
addiction was our first application with my colleague Terry Robinson here at the
University of Michigan.
When we discovered the difference between liking and wanting systems.
And the reason for the addiction application was because it was a known almost
forever that does drugs of abuse.
Not only activate,
don't mean systems,
but they can actually permanently change them in some ways,
including one way call sensitization that makes those dumping mean systems
hyperreactive to drugs in the future and to drug we need to queue.
And an addict,
if a person was undergoing sensitization of their dope mean systems,
this could create a form of addiction where they want rewards even if they
didn't like those rewards anymore.
And some addicts might fit this sort of characterization.
Addiction was the first application and that was as far as I thought we could
ever go.
Um,
no,
I'm not actually a number of years ago,
about 10 years ago,
another colleague here in social psychology,
Robert Science suggest it to me at the time that wanting versus liking would
have wider psychological applications beyond addiction.
And I thought,
well that's interesting,
but you only had a mechanism for nowcan means sensitization and I just couldn't
go there.
But in the last 10 years or so,
a number of other people have gone to other applications from eating disorders
to things that can happen even in schizophrenia and some other forms of
psychological pursuits,
sometimes of of ideas and things that can become very intense.
And it may actually be that the distinction between wanting versus liking plays
out in a number of clinical conditions.
So it might have more general applications.
That's something that's kind of exciting.
This is just getting to emerge.
Okay.
Well I was going to say,
you know,
your work has really been a model for some of the findings that we've been
discovering in our lab.
Applying it to disorders like bipolar disorder,
right?
That seemed to involve dysfunction both and liking and wanting.
That's a marvelous application that you're doing and I think it's really
fascinating.
Yeah,
well we owe it all to your work here as do many other,
you know,
clinical psychology researchers trying to understand the nature of reward
dysfunction.
Uh,
so we have to thank you for those discoveries.
Um,
but on this note,
you know,
I wonder sort of how do you think we can apply these models,
of dysregulated,
either liking andwe are wanting ultimately towards aiding in differential
diagnosis or developing really,
you know,
process driven,
uh,
you know,
interventions for disorders ranging from addiction to schizophrenia,
perhaps even to mood disorders like bipolar disorder or depression.
Well,
I love your emphasis on process based explanation.
I think that's exactly what you want to do.
And we don't have a roadmap in the beginning for how it's gonna play out for how
the wanting liking distinction will apply to these things with any other process
distinction.
But I think if we're sensitive to processes and if people like you who are
actually looking at the clinical disorders teasing apart the processes,
that's really marvelous and that's going to give a better signature to what
these disorders really hard.
And at the same time,
people like me who are sort of just exploring the basic mechanisms of
psychological processes,
what the nature of the basic psychological processes are.
Um,
there may be further developments that have just from is.
So I think it's marvelous to kind of meet in the middle and we don't know where
we're going to end up.
But by playing a lot of attention to the processes,
we will probably end up in a bedroom.
That's a lovely note to think about.
And I think many people will take those kernels of wisdom as they try to move
forward and develop these models of understanding,
you know,
basic mechanisms of reward as well as when it goes awry.
Um,
I wanted to ask you about another area of your research,
which is investigating how conscious as well as unconscious emotions can be
involved in everyday pleasures and desires.
I know this is a topic that probably interests a lot of people out there
listening to this.
So I wondered if you could stay a little bit about the neuro basis of these
conscious and unconscious feelings.
Like pleasure for example.
Well,
I wish I could say something reasonable about the neural basis of conscious
versus unconscious distinction and I think that's a major challenge for us all.
It's very hard to do that.
But the basic distinction between conscious pleasure and unconscious pleasure,
which is still very much up in the air.
It was sort of started with people like Bob Science or social psychologists who
was interested in sort of immediate unconscious emotional reactions that
happened before there was the opportunity for much thinking and people who
started in the 1970s eighties advancing that idea.
People like John Kill strong morning almost in the psychological side and people
like Joe [inaudible],
Tonio Demassio on sort of the neuroscience side have been entertaining for many
years that the essence of pleasure and displeasure,
the essence of emotion,
like not being conscious and whether it's conscious or not,
that goes way back for he'd had an opinion and he actually wrote that there was
no such thing as unconscious emotion.
Very,
very surprising since he thought so much.
What else could be unconscious?
The arguments going back and forth over the agents,
there is evidence now I think habitancy leaks that there might be unconscious
emotional reactions and my colleague Gilder Winkleman is valid.
You CSD has contributed some of that evidence.
I believe that there can be unconscious emotional processes,
but the story still playing out,
right?
So the evidence is still coming in.
We need a lot now on the neuroscience side,
you know,
in one sense we have a very sensible story for many years that um,
prefrontal cortex,
so special in humans might be the basis for our conscious emotion and some
subcortical mechanisms of emotion might be sort of the basis of unconscious
emotional processing sustains.
Yes.
And I think that story is plausible.
I've said it myself and written it myself with colleagues,
but probably in the end there isn't much evidence for it.
And there's actually more and more evidence against that particular distinction.
Prefrontal cortex is going to be the seat of consciousness.
Subcortical structures would be neat with the office unconscious,
what the real truth is.
That's harder to say,
but it's a great topic for anybody interested in brain mechanisms of
consciousness.
And hopefully in the next year,
new psychologists and neuroscientists we'll find out.
Excellent.
I mean,
do you think,
I know it sounds like this is a really wide open field with a lot of room for
discovery.
Do we have a sense of what might be the implications?
The more we learn about unconscious and conscious pleasure,
you know,
uh,
for decision making for example,
or you know,
what kind of implications with these different levels of pleasure have in our
everyday behaviors.
I think that's such a great question.
June.
And there's bound to be implications.
If there really is a distinction between unconscious emotions and conscious
ones,
there's bound to be,
um,
applications,
implications of that for the basis of decision making,
what it's going to turn out to be.
Of course,
that's an open question.
But what's marvelous now is that I think the psychology and neuroscience,
neurosciences,
pleasure is making great bounds motion can make great bounds like colleague
Morton,
crinkle pocket Oxford University and sort of helped lead the way in the last 10
years on sort of of neuroscience and pleasure developing them and trying to put
that on the table in the morning formula.
And the psychology and neuroscience of conscious versus unconscious processes is
something which kind of moves in fits and starts.
But it's made a lot of progress at moments in the last decade or so.
Um,
so I think,
you know,
these could come together.
There's so much room for more progress on both of those types of things.
So it's really,
it's for the future people who watch these videos,
um,
it's,
it's really in their hands.
When you mentioned the future and sort of,
you know,
where it may go.
And so that leads me to the question I wanted to ask you,
which just sort of,
where do you see kind of the,
the face of the future headed and emotion research?
Well,
like I think that emotion research and motion neuroscience is right for a lot
more progress.
You,
even though emotion and an asset to pleasure displeasure have been topics in
psychology for a hundred years,
a hundred years,
they've been relatively new to collect compared to the amount of detention and
progress has been made in cognition and learning in your brand perception it,
social interactions with other psychological upon assistance.
But progress can be made into motion.
Yeah.
Pleasure assets in neuroscience.
So it's something which I think if we're willing to engage the processes,
take an open mind,
be willing to encounter answers that at this moment we can't even conceive,
then people will find really interesting new answers in a lot of progress to be
made.
It's yet to be cracked open this topic,
but it can.
So when you give advice to students who are thinking about maybe toying with the
idea of embarking in this mysterious and wide open field of emotion,
what kind of advice do you usually give them?
Well,
I'd say,
you know,
for anybody considering a career in psychology or neuroscience,
we want to follow your deepest interests.
Do you want to find something,
a phenomenon of question that really excites you is this is the question basis
of pleasured motion psychologically great relation of dogs to conscious versus
unconscious processing.
If this was the question that really excites you,
we just want to go with that and you want to find a phenomenal,
I mean in the end we need to question and we all need something to study,
some sort of aspect of emotion,
some something that's happening.
It has to kind of wrap our question around this phenomenon that we can actually,
so look for phenomenon and interesting and if you find one,
jump on it and then just study it,
study it,
look for the processes involved,
and he may sign something.
Well,
thank you so much for speaking with us today.
Can,
um,
it was terrific hearing your thoughts to these provocative questions about what
got you here in the first place,
the kinds of projects you've been doing and where you see the future headed
from.
Well,
it's been great to talk with you,
Julian.
Thank you so much.
Good luck.
Thank you.
So this concludes our experts and emotion interview with Dr. Kent Berridge from
the University of Michigan.